what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to Comics explain and it's
time for another top 10 video as we
continue our ride on this bandwagon
until it runs out and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is a family-friendly
environment right they're owned by
Disney it's it's Mom and Dad and little
Timmy and whatever their daughter's name
is and they go see the Marvel movies and
just have a rip-run good time and
because of that this is a list of the 10
stories in my mind the top 10 stories
that the Marvel Cinematic Universe
probably will never be able to make just
because of how dark they are and kicking
our list off we actually have a what if
story from what if issue number 94
called Juggernaut the kingdom of Cain or
as I like to call it Juggernaut Kills
the Marvel Universe literally what
happens in this story is that it's
somewhere along the line in their
initial confrontation in Marvel Comics
The Juggernaut kills Professor Xavier
shortly after that the signal programs
activated and you kind of get Days of
Future Past like in the movie when the
Sentinels were basically killing mutants
everywhere they could find them the
difference here is that the first thing
to Sentinels did is they killed The
Avengers in the Fantastic Four denza
wiped those guys out and pretty much any
non-mutant superpowered being that was
there following that they turned on
their creator who was presumably Stephen
Lang no relation to Scotland and that
they ultimately modified their own
programming and when they did that they
basically started kind of emitting this
lethal radiation across the world Kane
Marco is the only being on Earth that's
immune to it likely because of the
Crimson gym of sidorak and his Cosmic
enhancements from the cosmic entity
sitarak if you guys don't know who that
is check out the last video that we made
at the end of this video which is the
top 10 characters that are too powerful
for the MCU but the thing behind this is
that Kane Marco basically travels the
world trying to find life Humanity
anything and he just can't really find
it at all until he ultimately stumbles
across a giant Cavern that has the
Iceman Bobby Drake and when Iceman will
not let Juggernaut through juggernaut's
Timber gets the better of him and he
kills Bobby Drake by Smashing through
the ice wall he finds this just great
big huge door and when he gets inside he
finds Quicksilver and he finds Scarlet
Witch and he finds humanity and he finds
a whole bunch of mutants and they're all
gathered together they're all United
under the singular cause of trying to
survive King Marco is excited he's so
happy to see him and they immediately
cuss him out and the reason why is
because by Smashing down the barrier he
let in the lethal radiation he's gonna
kill them all they're all going to die
because of radiation poisoning and it's
okay Marco ended up killing what was
left of Humanity on Earth pretty bleak
but I will say this none of the stories
on this list are anywhere near as Bleak
as number one and I'm sure most people
who are familiar with my channel know
exactly which that one's going to be but
coming in at number nine is Punisher
versus the Marvel Universe by the way
we're gonna have a few Punisher videos
on this list because you know Frank
Castle is pretty dark so there's
Punisher Kills the Marvel Universe then
there's Punisher versus the Marvel
Universe Punisher versus the Marvel
Universe in my opinion is actually the
darkest of the two and here's the reason
why while it is Punisher versus the
Marvel Universe it's more of a
spider-man-centric story but what ended
up happening is Peter Parker was
basically infected with a virus that was
similar to a zombie virus but not quite
and that Peter Parker ended up infecting
the people in the city of New York the
problem is this virus had an incubation
period so much like covid-19 people who
were on planes didn't know they had it
and they scattered it to the rest of the
world and when that happened the entire
world basically collapsed but that's not
what makes the story dark what makes the
story dark are the things that happen to
the various superheroes in this story
here's a really good example Iron Man
you ever imagined what it would be like
if Iron Man's suit just shut down and he
died inside of it that happens in this
story that in the midst of this whole
great big huge thing there's basically
an EMP effectively that goes off and
when that happens Iron Man suit shuts
down and as soon as the suit shuts down
he's stuck inside of it now there's one
point in this story and it's it's kind
of chilling and pretty haunting but
there's one point in this story where
Punisher is talking about it and he's
like they said it was like three days or
five days or something like that before
the screaming finally stopped so
essentially Iron Man's suit became a
tomb and he screamed for like three to
five days to get people to get them out
of there nobody could get the suit open
and he ultimately died trapped inside of
his own Iron Man suit those of you guys
out there who are claustrophobic hey
it's a terrible situation man it was
pretty bad but moving on to number eight
is a story that we actually got a bit of
a variation of but not quite Old Man
Logan now Old Man Logan is a story that
has not officially had a comic
adaptation done in movie 4. the closest
we got was Logan but they changed a few
things for example Xavier was the one
who killed the X-Men and there basically
were no other superheroes in Old Man
Logan it's a whole different Beast so
the Logan film feels more like X-Men
meets The Unforgiven movie if you guys
ever saw Unforgiven phenomenal film if
you haven't seen it already but the way
this played out is that in the Old Man
Logan Universe The Red Skull had come to
the realization that because all the
different villains had been losing to
all the different superheroes instead of
just repeating the same process where
Mysterio fights Spider-Man and different
things like that why not switch things
around and and why not take villains and
have them face off against superheroes
based on their abilities and who they're
the most suited for and so what ends up
happening here is Jubilee who's kind of
like the cheerleader of the X-Men is
basically just chilling in the X-Men
mansion one day and then suddenly it's
just a boatload of SOS calls the
Fantastic Four The Avengers Alpha flight
who nobody cares about the Inhumans who
you know rightfully die those guys suck
they can't do anything but basically
everybody was asking for help right at
that moment all the most notable
villains of the X-Men come busting into
the Xavier Institute Juggernaut
apocalypse like like Omega Red all those
guys Wolverine is like the only one
present right he pops his claws he's
getting the kids out of there he's
killing all the bad guys Wolverine flies
into a Berserker rage and Slaughters
them all and then right at that moment
Mysterio shows up and Mysterio says the
villains of this Earth thank you for
your contribution Wolverine come to find
out the Red Skull realized that because
Wolverine's entire thing is his senses
his sense of smell and touch and taste
and all that kind of of stuff who better
to manipulate those senses than Mysterio
the Master of Illusions so all those
villains were never there instead of
Wolverine killing the various villains
that had shown up that were part of the
X-Men's roster what Wolverine have been
doing was killing the X-Men following
that he basically just refuses to pop
his claws for the next 50 years and
that's just the tip of the iceberg right
like pretty much all the superheroes
that you know of dive like Ant-Man dies
and in fact there's this kid that
discovers the helmet of Ant-Man and
charges people like a nickel or
something like that to cross a bridge
those who don't do it he commands the
ants to eat them it's pretty brutal The
Incredible Hulk has his whole thing
which like the Hulk family and all that
kind of stuff it's a whole different
Beast the whole family is the result of
like this crazy relationship between the
Incredible Hulk and She-Hulk because
they both went insane because of the
radiation and started procreating
there's other theories as to how it
happened which we won't talk about here
but the important thing is that the
universe is pretty bleak and it's pretty
dark kind of a fun fact you end up
finding out Old Man Logan crosses over
into the main Marvel Universe following
the death of the original Wolverine and
his stories are really really cool but
following that we go into number seven
which is Thor Vikings and Thor Vikings
is probably a story you've never heard
of we have covered it here on Comics
explained that was part of Marvel Max
those of you guys who don't know what
Marvel Max is Once Upon a Time When I
say once upon a time I mean like in 2001
Marvel had the question what if we
created stories that had like nudity and
cussing in the whole nine yards and they
were geared for adults enter Marvel Max
so this Thor's story basically deals
with Vikings coming back from the dead
and then trying to conquer the city of
Manhattan and Thor has to face off
against them it's not really the premise
of the story that makes it dark this is
one of those kind of stereotypical Blood
and Guts cussing hyper violence all that
kind of stuff it's one of those kind of
stories not a whole lot to go on here
but it's just the insane sheer level of
violence in this story is enough that
they couldn't do it right like imagine
the Deadpool film but like three times
more violent and Marvel Cinematic
Universe property it's just not gonna
happen but speaking of Deadpool
fool Kills the Marvel universe so this
story is just one of the funniest
stories you're ever going to see and
honestly I could see the Marvel
Cinematic Universe adapting this story
to a degree and the way that like Old
Man Logan was adopted in the film Logan
so just changing some stuff around but
more or less having the same general
premise but for those of you guys who
don't know Deadpool kills the Marvel
universe is actually part of a Trilogy
that you have Deadpool kills a Marvel
Universe then you have Deadpool
killustrated and then you have Deadpool
kills Deadpool so the way this played
out is that in an alternate reality
Deadpool was just as insane as you
expect him to be and so there was
basically an attempt to cure him of his
Insanity the consequence of this was
that he actually realized he was a
fictional character that nothing that
was happening was real so he just starts
killing everybody like literally
everyone the first issue opens with him
killing uwa to The Watcher and this guy
does it in some of the most insane but
also creative ways so in order to kill
Luke Cage because Luke Cage has
Bulletproof Skin Deadpool ends up taking
like explosives and hem particles to
shrink them down and so when Luke Cage
was eating food he was actually eating
bombs and then Deadpool detonates him
and kills Luke Cage it was stuff like
that right it was just crazy
circumstances like that it was amazing
it was phenomenal some of how he managed
to kill Galactus we never found out how
but the story is phenomenal because it's
just this great blend of like comedy and
action and lots and lots of killing but
it is amazing
here on comments explaining what I'll do
in order to make things easier for you
all so you don't have to keep track
yourself it's down in the comments
section you will see a link to all the
different videos that we've done that
basically are on this list assuming that
we've done them right if we haven't then
let me know down in the comments and
I'll certainly cover one of them but
moving on past Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe and into our number five spot
is a story that most most of you out
there who have never read Comics have
never heard of but it's one of my
all-time favorites God loves man kills
now this is a great story and there are
ample reasons as to why the Marvel
Cinematic Universe won't do this here's
the first reason so in this story you
basically have a guy named William
Striker and this guy is probably one of
the greatest villains ever introduced in
Marvel Comics this guy has no powers he
does he's not a telepath he can't alter
reality he can't move things with his
mind none of that stuff instead the
beauty of William Striker is that he's a
religious fundamentalist who thinks it's
his mission from God to kill mutants and
so what he does is he ends up forming a
group called The purifiers this story
opens up with the purifiers chasing down
these kids and like that's it it's it
opens up like that now the reality here
is that when this story was written by
Chris Claremont it was less about like
the ultra violence and all that kind of
stuff and it was designed to be an
allegory of race relations in the United
States at the time and so instead of the
comic book ending with some great big
huge fight between the X-Men and the
purifiers which that does actually
happen in the story and did some amazing
like when they capture when they kidnap
like Professor Xavier and like other
X-Men it's pretty baller the purifiers
they knew what they were doing man they
were very very organized but the comic
actually ends with the debate between
Cyclops and William Striker and what
Cyclops does is he actually argues if
God created humanity and the mutant
population is a genetic offshoot of
humanity then were the Reed like God's
the reason we exist in the first place
but he basically Corners William Striker
using his own logic and so William
Striker pulls a gun and then he shoots
the Cyclops and I think he hits
Nightcrawler then he's arrested by the
cops like that's basically it the guy
gets taken away because the world sees
him for what he is which is just a crazy
religious fanatic and then all the
people who sided with him basically have
to look other people in the eye and it's
going to be like yeah I got swept up in
the fervor of you know religious
zealotry yeah hey wanna go grab a beer
you know it happens you know I don't
know what to tell you right like that
kind of a thing so it was it was it was
kind of nuts but the story itself is
great where there's a multitude of
reasons why the MCU won't do this first
of all if they introduce a villain and
basically the reason why he's a bad guy
isn't because of his religious zealotry
they're gonna piss off all the
Christians in the United States right
like 80 of the US population is going to
be pissed some subject of that is
probably going to protest so they don't
want to end up losing that kind of money
so they're not going to make that but
you also had a moment in the comic when
you had a girl named Kitty prod and
kitty Pride who most of you know from
just the X-Men films produced by Fox
that she is a character that can walk
through walls but she has a friend who's
a human and this friend is named Frankie
who is a black woman what ends up
happening is somebody runs up on Kitty
pride and Frankie and then literally
starts calling Frankie like a mutant
lover and that kind of thing and Frankie
tells Kitty probably you have to let it
go because Kitty Pride starts freaking
out and so PewDiePie looks at her and
says would you say the same thing if
they made a statement similar to that
but based on your skin color would you
respond the same way would you say well
you gotta let it go right or would it
piss you off you know it's one of those
really really cool circumstances in the
comic that was designed to talk about
race relations back then and Chris
Claremont put the word in there he
didn't censor it out it was not censored
out at all it's there for the world to
see but it was a landmark and
significant story but for those reasons
the Marvel Cinematic Universe but we get
into the number four spot this is Hulk
the end now in Marvel Comics you had a
series of comics that were called the
end they were basically like the end of
the road for different superheroes in
some cases they just retired and passed
the mantle On to the Next Generation for
other Heroes things were really Bleak
for the Incredible Hulk the way this
played out is that the world had just
been engulfed in a nuclear Holocaust
right like literally just everybody was
essentially killed the Heroes all that
kind of stuff the only life left on
Earth are basically whatever's
irradiated like giant bugs and things
like that or the Incredible Hulk slash
Bruce Banner but Bruce Banner is
actually aging up that he's not Immortal
where he doesn't stay youthful forever
so he's basically an old man at this
point now the Incredible Hulk is aging
as well right he's got gray hair
different things like that but one of
the things that it talks about is this
idea that like Bruce Banner sets up
surveillance systems to see what happens
to the Incredible Hulk when the
Incredible Hulk Persona takes over
because at this point in time Marvel had
not established that Bruce Banner could
still understand what the Hulk was doing
when the Hulk Persona had essentially
manifested and so as a result of this
the the Bruce Banner sees things like
the Incredible Hulk every day basically
gets eaten alive by like these giant
irradiated bugs and then heal
so in the Marvel Cinematic Universe when
Mark Ruffalo was talking about trying to
take that route which you should never
do this is the story that they got that
from and there were other stories where
that kind of thing happened as well but
the reality here is that it's incredibly
Bleak there does come a point when the
Bruce Banner Persona dies of a heart
attack and the Incredible Hulk finally
gets what he always wanted which is to
be left alone but the Incredible Hulk is
the only living thing on Earth the sole
survivor of the Earth itself outside of
just giant bugs and things like that but
the story ends on a really Bleak and sad
note because effectively what you're
being told is that from that point until
whenever the Incredible Hulk happens to
die of old age which could be thousands
of years he'll be the only being on
Earth that life will never come back
because it's just in a radiated
Wasteland life can't grow so it's pretty
brutal and it's pretty dark but it's
nowhere near as dark as our top three
stories so coming in at number three is
another comic that belongs to the end
and I'm sure those of you guys who are a
fan of my channel knew that this story
was coming Punisher the end this is a
bleak and a dark story so very similar
to the premise of Hulk the end that the
world had been engulfed in a nuclear war
the difference here is that Frank Castle
along with a handful of other prisoners
basically end up Surviving the whole
thing because they're locked in a bunker
but along the way Frank Castle finds out
that there's actually another bunker out
there in the world that houses the
wealthy and Powerful of the world Q
YouTube demonetizing this video because
it doesn't show brands in a positive
light but the thing behind this is that
Frank Castle realizes that it was like
government officials and it was
corporations and things like that that
pushed the world to the brink where this
nuclear war even happened in the first
place but Frank Castle makes his way
along the irradiated Wasteland after
killing all the prisoners who were left
in that prison and literally it's stuff
like the clouds are on fire from like
the nuclear explosions and things like
that but he ends up finally coming
across the bunker where there's
survivors and once he gets in there it
really is all these businessmen and
business women and like politicians and
so on and so forth and what they're
doing is they're actually setting up an
entire reproduction chamber that what
they had done here is they had found a
means to basically grow human beings and
what they would do is repopulate the
earth well Frank Castle comes to the
decision that if people who run
corporations CEOs and all these crooked
politicians and all that kind of stuff
if they're the ones that caused all of
this in the first place and they start
repopulating the Earth they're gonna
screw it up so he kills all the
politicians and businessmen and business
women who were there and then he turns
his sights to like those little tiny
incubation Chambers and he basically
decides that humanity is a horrible
thing humanity is just a terrible thing
right all humanity is going to do is
screw things up because he's an extreme
misanthrope Humanity will learn nothing
from its mistakes so the best thing that
Frank Castle can do for the world itself
is to eliminate what's left of humanity
so he destroys them all and by doing so
with all the doctors and everything like
that bunker was the last one because
they show him or they they haven't
listened to like a broadcast from the
bunker where the president was the
president had gone insane he'd kill
everybody in the bunker and then took
himself out right so he was it was nuts
it was a pretty wild thing but
eradicating what's left of humanity
Frank Castle just kind of wanders into
the flames and dies of radiation
sickness and so Punisher effectively
kills everybody on Earth but following
this we go into number two which is not
really just one story but a series of
stories Punisher MAX by Garth Ennis so
Punisher MAX is considered the
definitive Punisher run if ever there
were a series of comics that you should
read that belong to the Punisher it's
Punisher MAX and like that's it right
it's just their their phenomenal stories
Punisher born is basically the
explanation of how Frank Castle became
Frank Castle outside of like the death
of his family that like it was not the
death of his family that sent him down
that path that he had basically made a
deal with the devil years beforehand
when he was in the Vietnam War it was
absolutely crazy but Punisher MAX just
has a series of hyperviolent extremely
crazy stories where like some of the
most insane things happen right girls in
white dresses uh oh my God the slavers
Barracuda was another crazy one that
happened I would say probably the single
greatest monologue was up is down and
black is white where Frank Castle talks
about how like he has this dream from
time to time and in the Stream like he
doesn't stop he kills all the
politicians drug dealers the whole nine
yards and then he looks around and he
sees all these people who had like
elected these crooked politicians and
all these people who stood by and did
nothing as the world fall fell apart and
he sees just people in general as being
a problem right he's like politicians
didn't just walk into office and take it
you put them there which means you're as
screwed up as they are because you
didn't see a problem with them so what
he says is in this dream that basically
he starts to pull the trigger and then
he wakes up but it's kind of a Prelude
to the events of like Punisher the end
where ultimately Frank Castle's actions
of dooming the entirety of humanity come
to fruition but not quite directly
because this sort of came before all
that stuff it's amazing right it's just
a ridiculously awesome story but it's
way too dark and way too violent for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but this leads
us to number one what is arguably the
single not even arguably what is
inarguably definitively resolutely
absolutely not a debatable point the
single darkest story and the entirety of
Marvel Comics Marvel ruins so Marvel
ruins oh my God we cover this story
right everything like that like the
worst case scenario happens in Marvel
Comics Marvel ruins is unnecessarily
dark it is unnecessarily brutal right
it's terrible so here's the thing you
know like in Marvel Comics Bruce Banner
is exposed to the gamma bomb and he
becomes the Incredible Hulk instead of
just dying as an irradiated mass of
tumors which is what would happen in the
real world that happens in this story
that instead of the superheroes
undergoing these experiences right these
crazy experiments and then in turn like
becoming superheroes they succumb to
what would likely happen in the real
world so like when Marvel and the cree
show up on Earth they're put in an
internment camp and like disease and all
that kind of stuff is rampant
enchantress from the Asgardian Mythos
she's an adult film star like Nick Fury
goes crazy and basically offs himself
because he's like the world is so
screwed Gene gray of the X-Men's a
hooker I mean it's stuff like that right
probably the single craziest moment that
happens in this story it's probably the
the single most just that [ __ ] moment
ever in the history of a Marvel comic
check this out it's absolutely Bonkers
so what ends up happening is I think
it's the reporter somebody somebody's on
an airplane and Mystique is there right
Mystique is a shape-shifter the problem
with this is that unlike Marvel Comics
where Mystique just shapeshifts into
people and all that kind of stuff and
does whatever she wants to do in Marvel
ruins she's gone insane because of all
the people she's duplicated so all those
personalities are all swirling up there
in her head and she starts to lose
control of her powers on the flight
while that's going on you end up having
something going on with Magneto because
it all takes place at an airport I can't
remember exactly what it is it happens
with Magneto but whatever the case is
instead of Magneto being a guy that can
like control magnetism on a whim that
what he has is basically a power
dampening harness because he can't
control his magnetic powers the power
dampening harness is basically damaged
and when that happens everything around
Magneto just gets directly pulled into
him because he's like a giant magnet
right like every piece of metal the
plane explodes just all kinds of crazy
violence and and crazy situations it's
one of those one of the darkest stories
out there right it's just one of the
single darkest stories what's also
really messed up here is that Professor
Xavier does exist in that story but his
situation is very Cloak and Dagger that
what it looks like is that instead of
him becoming the leader of the X-Men and
teaching them how to use their powers
and different things like that that he's
made himself president of the United
States by using his telepathy and then
in turn experiments on the mutant
population like you know well welding
Cyclops his eyes shut different things
like that it's it's dark the story is
crazy dark suffice it to say you will
never ever under any circumstances see
moral ruins in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that's never going to happen
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace